welcome to this video playing a wall
town provider from Argentina Clayton
before he's had with a sixty-three
percent score five wins three losses for
him so quite a good quality good result
okay so we got a queen's gambit sloth
said I think it's just a slap right away
the Queens gambit sloth okay in this
particular position what about c phi f
can i do that let's try that going to
him well just try just see is got 94 my
idea was Queen a fire but he's got night
a form a beam hmm and we should be too
that's not good okay maybe I can get the
pot back with this before a five does
not seem to be the case
Quincy 7 this was wasn't a great idea
make I cannot take twice because of
Bishop f7
hmm
yeah that's really a bad opening what
the what the hmm
do I get get get out of this cannot even
play be 5 p.m. or be six takes takes
bishop f7 still ok let's do something
entirely different maybe I can use the
fact that the night is somewhat offside
to gain some time Bishop f5 whoop dat
moves like that ok then the night
slightly off side look here which rook
typical case one thing that he needs to
be aware of is the move Queenie form
that can really help me yeah here
Queenie form attacking of the rook and
the night it's got a 93 but then I have
queen before and I get the pawn back I
believe ok
hmm it was probably quite bad position
out of the opening now it seems to be
okay at least on the board i'm still
very much done on time but the position
should be okay
yeah trying to play for activity am
queen d3 attacking the beep on a small
block d3 is also a mix that might happen
soon 25 would be double attack Bishop
and pawn okay if I get one of those
pawns I'm okay at least okay okay cannot
take here and it's fairly active maybe I
get in rook be five
maybe you'll be fine attacking the b2
pond it's not that I cannot take it
quickly but the rock on b5 is always
keeping this pressure on okay this this
can easily lead to a total
simplification and need to take no use
in spending time yeah another anything
better than probably not Roxy 6 and then
taking on be too I will pour down but
four against three the time is the only
issue no problem at all with an
increment but here can be tricky
defending this end game upon down always
start with h 5 pretender projecting g4
yeah once you have h 5 in it so just
very much a matter of patience and stay
focused because it sits gently not like
that white can do much check time
warning check
check I should have should not have
allowed that actually but ok it's it's
nothing nothing bad happened check check
check check check hi no I'm in porn up
that's funny of course it's it's a dead
Robert check check draw Jared game plan
would have played this on time and
forever be funny yeah okay so I somehow
survived this this fishy opening the the
problem is whatever I forgot about there
is a line where the corn is on a seven
it's just the same position but the pawn
is on is happen and this is a big
differences this night a for now is
always looking at this so I'm really
just a pawn down here i believe it's
just just too terribly bad position
somehow got out of it yeah here it's
about equal and then somehow it it got
to this i mean okay in at the end this
rook endgame is also equal in a way it's
just a bit uncomfortable that you still
need to play it it is a draw ever
sorry it's very important to get in this
h5 move which allows for portraits if
white tries to play d4 and this makes it
very difficult for him to get anything
anything going in very tough to lose
this this end game you can if you have
little time and um it gets gets to be a
very very long game but for instance you
shouldn't really lose it if you have a
decent increment in a tournament game
alright thanks for watching